officials say at least eight six people
rather have been killed after a powerful
earthquake in southern Mexico the
epicenter of the quake was located near
the Pacific coast in the state of Oaxaca
the tremors knocked out power and caused
severe damage in some areas pavements
wobbled hundreds of kilometers away in
Mexico City standing on shaky ground and
feeling the earth swaying beneath one's
feet shockwaves from a powerful
earthquake brought towns and cities
across Mexico to a halt residents
flooded the streets seeking safety on
shifting pavement it was very strong I
had never felt such a strong earthquake
only in 1985
today's earthquake felt very very strong
we were so afraid it was pretty severe
and with kovat 19 you think what's next
hospitals were affected too
but while medical staff and patients
were evacuated those suffering from the
corona virus remained isolated inside I
felt how the bed was moving I was
sleeping and then I saw how the curtains
everything was moving the quake hit at a
time when Mexico was already reeling
from the corona virus pandemic which has
claimed more than 22,000 lives so far
Latin America's second highest toll but
the tremors effects could have been much
worse
Mexico's president announced that the
country's infrastructure suffered no
serious damage but he warned citizens to
remain cautious just busy
after the strong 7.5 earthquake
see that there have been 147 aftershocks
the mall okay so they recommend that we
remain alert and attentive Indian this
bindle
but while feeling the aftershocks some
Mexicans preferred appealing to a higher
power